Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 is coming
real soon and I've been waiting for this
game ever since the post-credits
cutscene of 2019's Modern Warfare so
here's what I'm looking forward to and
what I'm not looking forward to in both
the campaign and multiplayer
so good news first biggest thing I'm
excited for right off the bat is the
campaign that continues retelling the
story of Task Force 141 we last Saw
price having averted a nuclear disaster
at the end of Warzone season 6 which
supposedly tied into the campaign we've
seen some of our favorites already like
soap gas price and ghost who hopefully
might not die in this retelling of the
story at least not yet right but lucky
for us the campaign has an early access
period that goes live one week before
launch so you can play without feeling
like you're getting behind in
multiplayer now if you've seen any of my
other videos live streams or my
discussions with gamespot's Jake Decker
or Aaron Samson you'll know where I come
from when it comes to Call of Duty and
my love for COD campaigns straight up
I'm a story boy through and through this
campaign has night Ops repelling down
buildings car chases and ship assaults
with all these missions taking influence
from the most popular Call of Duty
missions like all gillied up sounds like
a recipe for success and I'm hoping it
lives up to the expectations I've got
when I start streaming it on day one for
Gamespot now when it comes to story
campaigns and first person shooters back
in the day I started out with Medal of
Honor Frontline and Call of Duty 2 big
Red One but my first real encounter with
cod's campaign during the peak of the
360 days came with Modern Warfare 2 in
2009 that's right I'm blasphemously
played Modern Warfare 2's campaign
before Modern Warfare 1 and although I
love the first modern warfare the
original campaign for two is just out of
this world to me and holds so much
Nostalgia because it was my first
granted I was super confused when you
rescue price when you first called
McTavish soap but when I went back and
played Modern Warfare 1 and then
replayed two it all came together
honestly I can't think of action set
pieces in any game as a whole without
immediately thinking about sprinting
across fabula rooftops and leaping into
a waiting helicopter whenever I played
the campaign after school for all the
incredible set pieces and other games
like Uncharted there was an equally
cinematic one for me and the Modern
Warfare campaigns I mean maybe some of
you Gamers from my generation feel the
same or you might think fondly about
other games like the original Black Ops
and no matter what Call of Duty was your
first we can all pretty much agree on
one thing I hope which is the campaigns
are usually exceptional and worth the
price of admission alone now with
Graphics from movie style set pieces to
Wicked plot twists and sick villains the
Cod campaigns are something I look
forward to every release call me casual
but I know I'm not the only one who is
disappointed when Black Ops 4 didn't
have a campaign now so far we've only
seen the reveal of the Dark Water
Mission and Snippets from the brand new
campaign trailer released earlier Dark
Water looked dope to me but some people
online felt that it looked like a rehash
of the original modern warfare's opening
ship Mission which bare the cutscenes
from the new trailer though dude
seriously I had to pause and Double Take
because I thought this was a live action
trailer the CGI and cutscenes look
really awesome and I cannot wait to bust
it out on my shiny series X or PC now
when we talk about the return of 141 oh
boy you know what I'm excited for and I
would love to see is if the new campaign
for Modern Warfare 2 lets you play as
different characters letting you swap
perspectives from mission to Mission in
the original Modern Warfare 2 you had a
roach who was kind of soap's Protege and
you had John Allen who gets involved in
one of the gnarliest Cod missions of all
time it even more shockingly has a Twist
that cuts his storyline short there was
also an Army Ranger perspective that
would be involved in all the missions
that took place back at home Stateside
the global conflict has my fingers
crossed that Task Force 141 will split
up at some point letting you take
different perspectives and play as so
price and maybe even some more folks now
keeping the Positive Vibes going the
campaign is all fine and good but as
Aaron likes say let's be honest like um
multiplayer is where Call of Duty's at
campaign you play for four six eight
hours at most then as a Call of Duty
player you spend 100 200 maybe many more
hours over in multiplayer thankfully we
went balls to the wall with the Early
Access and open beta for Modern Warfare
2's multiplayer and despite a few things
we wished were different the majority of
our feelings were really solid gun
handling overall feels dead on the money
despite some early adjustments needed to
get used to the admittedly Hefty kick
but beyond that it feels to me like I'm
kind of riding a bike it's like I never
took a break from Modern Warfare you
know part of that is thanks to how
welcoming the gameplay was for many of
us growing up even though the chat
lobbies back in the day were
you know something else I didn't get it
I have the oldest Xbox known to man no
you don't I bought mine on day one you
[ __ ] time
well mine didn't have it you have Uno
you [ __ ] dick I don't have it you
all of the good memories I've had with
Call of Duty particularly what 2019's
modern warfare which I really liked came
rushing back the guns the combat the new
quality of life adjustments
moment-to-moment gameplay is really
solid and is a big thing to be excited
for although I get it some folks aren't
stoked about the lack of slide canceling
or the fact that the minimap doesn't
always show people pop up on radar and I
see you but I don't know I kind of like
where the multiplayer is headed throwing
a rewarding battle pass and man Count Me
In there's also something that I like to
call the Modern Warfare versus Black Ops
effect and again now this is the part
where I remind you guys that your
mileage will vary but if you felt that
modern warfare games and Black Ops games
have always felt a little different
you're not wrong I've played every Cod
more or less and although I didn't
exactly hate the most recent cod in
Vanguard Black Ops cold war is a
different story
traditional arcadey three-lane maps and
fast-paced gameplay is just not my thing
but it probably is yours tactical
gameplay where you have to use your kit
to its full potential though and knowing
when to swap weapons for different
engagements plus needing to know all the
nitty-gritty spots in each map now that
sounds way more appealing to me and
Modern Warfare 2 is full of these
opportunities in its multiplayer
from spy cams that can be clutch and
prisoner rescue modes to drill charges
that you can stick to someone's back
there's a fantastic balance of gaminess
while rewarding player smarts Modern
Warfare 2's time to kill also isn't
necessarily that much longer than Black
Ops but this is offset by the sheer kick
and recoil the guns have which is a bit
heavy at first but with enough tinkering
adjustments and just getting used to it
all feels good the maps have several
layers and winding Pathways that can
take you through Close Quarter hallways
longer sight lines and second floor
outposts for different Vantage points
like in farm 19's crumbling buildings
now I get that I've been gassing up
Modern Warfare 2 all this time but this
game obviously will not be perfect sure
there are a lot of minor gripes and some
larger issues with the game that we go
in depth in our discussion about Modern
Warfare 2's multiplayer beta which you
should definitely check out for more but
let's pivot real quick and talk about
big picture concerns
so the bad news problem is that although
I could wax nostalgic all I want on the
campaign it is not all sunshine and
roses for starters it is not easy for a
Call of Duty campaign to just keep
delivering larger and larger explosions
without coming off as kind of pointless
for every great OG Modern Warfare 2
moment I can think about there was most
likely an equally plain moment in a game
like Advanced or Infinity Warfare or
Black Ops 2 and 3 character deaths
Expendable style action and campy we've
been here before style dialogue doesn't
always hit the same especially as I grow
more older and jaded what made Modern
Warfare 2019 so special is that it was
more grounded in the way it explored the
impact of War on characters and the
smaller scale Wars they wage and Modern
Warfare 2019 also hit on similar themes
but focus more on psychological tension
and Terror some levels like clean house
left your hands sweating when wondering
who was Friend or Foe the legacy of
missions like that leave a lot of
pressure for Modern Warfare 2 to match
these expectations and it's not really
guaranteed fingers crossed though now
you might have noticed in even in my
other videos there's been one game mode
that I have almost avoided talking about
all the time and it's because it just
flat out sucked yeah I'm talking about
Spec Ops the elephant in the room here
is that not everything in Modern Warfare
for 2019 was good and spec ops is the
epitome of this spec ops was cheap
grindy and not well thought through it's
going to be replaced from 2019 with a
smaller two-player version that leans
heavily on the new games AI which needed
some improvement based on the beta by
the way and you know no idea if this
will lead up to the eventual raids but
let's not pretend this was good to begin
with last time around alright there's
also a looming bigger problem that I
like to call the Activision effect
Activision likes to [ __ ] with everything
it touches and a big part of me is
warily waiting for something to happen
with modern warfare 2's live service
model especially from a give me more
money point of view if not at launch
then almost certainly in future season
passes Modern Warfare 2019 was really
tame at first when it came to cosmetics
and microtransactions with a lot of
skins being pretty neat milsim style
stuff then a long came Warzone and
suddenly we got crazier and crazier
skins compounded with Black Ops and
Vanguard all transitioning their skins
across games war zone 2.0 is meant to be
a pure reset to Warzone and I'm hoping
that with its release in November it
doesn't take away all the steam from
Modern Warfare 2. I'm especially hopeful
we get a proper live service battle pass
even though battle passes are now a dime
a dozen in this industry whatever method
Activision needs to take as long as it
doesn't keep pushing us to excessive
microtransactions that is what I'm
hoping for am I confident it will turn
out that way no not really there's
already a PlayStation exclusive Samurai
skin and Drew Mazar will start having
sports stars in the game like fortnite
so also Call of Duty Warzone over time
really strayed away from the Fantastic
challenge system of the original 2019
game that allowed you to earn blueprints
character outfits and gun skins instead
of opting more for timed experience
boost calling cards and things most
people don't really care about we want
to return to the former sadly though
there's too much money to be made by
putting in Michael Myers or killer
clowns or whatever so I already know
Activision is going to get their bag
eventually and just give us a few months
please to a year at least of unlocking
things through play like even the
default operators had a sick unlock Tree
in 2019. I'm just really worried they're
more than willing to reduce the quality
of life and direct people as often as
they can to the microtransaction store
that's no fun for anyone and hopefully
it'll be avoided so Modern Warfare 2 is
right around the corner with a weird
rolling launch like we've got The
Campaign coming up first in An Early
Access period Then the official base
launch with multiplayer and Warzone 2.0
at its heels with the November launch
I'm David and myself Aaron Sampson Jake
Decker and some other folks at Gamespot
will be coming in hot with some tips
guides live streams and a bunch of more
fun videos from Modern Warfare 2 coming
soon maybe even a hot taker too to we'll
see depends on how badly y'all yell at
me in the comments yeah until next time